Bienvenue.
Moi c’est Zeus.
Entrez dans le monde de
Immortals Fenyx Rising
Et le premier qui se moque de
mon accent se prends un éclair au cul.
L’Ile d’or est peuplée
de créatures mythologiques.
Des créatures qui n’ont
pas toujours existé.
Bref, c’est l’invention
des créatures mythologiques
vous avez lu le titre de la vidéo.
T’as changé un truc toi non ?
Bah je suis nouvelle connard.
Ah voilà, c’est ça.
Bon vous avez compris l’urgence
Typhon, le boss
Il veut un maximum de monstres terrifiants.
Pourquoi faire ?
Pour faire chier les humains.
- Bonne idée !
- Ça je déteste les humains.
Balancez des propals
je veux des monstres, dans 3000 ans,
on s’en souvient encore.
Allez-y.
Allez c’est parti, challenge hein ?
OK, j’ai du lourd.
Imaginez une femme, avec des crocs
et ses cheveux...
sont sales.
Ils puent et tout.
C’est des serpents.
Ah ouais, sympa.
Ça voudrait dire que ses ongles
sont aussi des serpents
parce que c’est la même matière en fait.
- Et en plus
- Ah c’est pas fini ?
Lorsque tu croises son regarde
tu te transformes en pierre.
La matière, pas le prénom.
Ah d’accord oui !
Parce que juste s’appeler Pierre
c’est pas si effrayant.
Surtout que si tu t’appelles déjà Pierre
le changement est moindre.
Oui, nul.
Du coup en parlant de nom.
Pour ta créature terrifiante là
Il nous faut un super nom.
J’ai !
La méduse.
C’était pas un animal ça ?
T’as pris un animal à la con
et tu veux nous faire croire que t’as travaillé ?
Non mais je vous promets
J’ai dit ça comme ça,
comme ça sortait
comme j’aurai pu dire, le chat.
Le chat aussi du coup.
La méduse.
Alors moi j’ai une créature
c’est un monstre, mi-homme
mi-cheval.
Oh, la rapidité du cheval
et l’intelligence de l’Homme
Très bonne idée ça.
Le chevomme.
Le centaure.
Le centaure., ça c’est mieux
on valide ça.
En plus, il va faire super peur
avec ses deux teubes.
Avec ses deux quoi ?
Avec ses deux teubes.
C’est-à-dire deux teubes ?
Globalement c’est ce que je vous avez dit,
c’est-à-dire qu’il y a
Là on est d’accord que c’est moitié Homme
avec toute l’anatomie de l’Homme.
et des fesses partent un cheval
avec tous les attributs de cheval.
On coupe au nombril.
Oui.
J’en ai un excellent.
Imaginez-le...
Minotaure.
Mi-homme
Mi-girafe.
Mi-sangsue
Mi-phasme, peut-être.
Mi-taureau.
- Homme/taureau.
- Ah c’est bien ça !
Et peut-être que cette fois-ci
on pourrait faire l’inverse
à savoir, une tête de taureau
mais un corps d’humain.
mais en fait c’est un taureau
qui court moins vite finalement.
Non parce qu’il est plus fin
donc il se faufile, c’est hyper sournois.
OK comme vous voulez pour le Minotaure.
- Et au niveau de
- Une seule teube oui.
D’accord.
Non mais bon, c’est bien
de préciser quand même je veux dire.
On a qu’à dire qu’à chaque fois
y’a qu’une seule teube.
C’est plus simple..
Oui.
Propal.
Le cerbère.
Un gros chien, avec plusieurs têtes.
Oh !
Combien ?
1 million.
Non.
Non, moi je disais plus genre 3 têtes.
Comme ça, en cas de débat
on peut décider,
ça évite d’avoir égalité.
3 c’est bien.
ça m’a inspiré de ouf.
Vous me dites !
Pas mal hein ?
Ah mais j’aurai peut-être
du préciser la race non ?
Ouais.
Ah la race attention,
c’est pas définit, on peut changer.
Moi j’avais pensé aussi à corgi
chihuahua
ou cavalier king charles !
Pour la race on va décider après.
mais cerbère c’est très bien c’est validé.
Yes !
Ah oui par contre, là y’a 3 têtes
donc c’est clair qu’il y a 3...
Non !
J’ai du très très lourd.
La harpie.
Mi-femme
Mi-rapace.
Elle est forte hein.
Alors là, j’avais...
ça.
ça c’est l’Homme, on l’a inventé
à la première réunion.
ça on l’a fait ouais.
Et non.
Non, non, ce n’est pas l’Homme.
Il a une particularité ?
Bien évidemment qu’il a une particularité
Il est en fait
très grand.
Y’a pas d’échelle en fait,
j’ai oublié.
C’est parce que, mais il est géant.
Et le nom ?
Le Géant.
Yes.
Une créature avec pleins de yeux
mais surtout pleins de bras.
- Oh super !
- Oui évidemment, une seule ?
Oui !
Là j’ai un super truc.
Un cheval blanc avec des ailes.
Pégase.
Ah, le nom en deux mots est bien
mais par contre
ça fait pas peur chef.
J’allais le dire.
C’est même plutôt pratique.
Oui mais c’est stylé.
Mais c’est stylé.
Bravo chef !
Une proposition peut-être ?
Oui ! Alors
pleins, au hasard, celle-là
C’est la même.
C’est encore le géant ça.
C’est... et non.
Encore l’échelle qui est différente ?
Non, cette fois-ci c’est pas l’échelle
T’essayes de nous refourguer les inventions du début
c’est bon on t’a grillé.
C’est la même chose.
Mais pas du tout, c’est une créature
qui n’a rien à voir...
Oh attendez, regardez !
Là-bas, c’est quoi ? C’est un aigle ?
On dirait un aigle
mais qui n’a pas la taille d’un aigle.
Qui aurait un peu la taille d’un petit héron.
Allô ? Excusez-moi.
On est en réu en fait.
Donc la proposition, c’est le cyclope.
Puisqu’il n’a qu’un seul oeil
et c’est ça, la particularité.
Attends, il a qu’un seul oeil ?
Ouais
Il est moins fort que le géant donc ?
Oui mais non parce que
c’est un œil qui est très grand.
Mais tu te fous de notre gueule ?
Tu bosses rien, le géant,
t’as mis du tipex dessus.
Avant c’était quoi ? La méduse ?
La méduse c’est un nom d’animal,
tu comprends ça ?
Et le géant, c’est un mec qui est géant.
Pas du tout, c’est un diptyque
le géant, le cyclope.
Vous comprenez pas
Moi je crée de la cohérence
entre mes créations
excusez-moi de bien faire mon boulot.
On le valide.
D’accord, OK pour le cyclope.
Alors j’ai un très bon
moite-moite figurez-vous
J’aime bien les moite-moite.
Alors, mi-lion
mi-aigle.
A parti de là c’est aigle.
Mais c’est pas rapide des pattes d’aigle.
Oui quitte à prendre de l’aigle,
tu prends les ailes.
Oui du coup on inverse,
on met le corps de l’aigle
avec la tête du lion et les pattes aussi.
OK, oui, bien joué.
Le griffon.
D’ailleurs un aigle ça a pas de...
Non mais attends mais d’accord
à ce moment là on fait n’importe quoi.
Je prends quoi, je prends le lion
et puis je lui rajoute une deuxième tête
une tête de serpent ?
Une troisième tête même !
Une tête...
de...
une tête de chèvre.
Et des ailes.
Et on appelle ça, la chimoune.
la chimère.
la chimère ?
Excellent ça la chimère.
Un lion, tête de chèvre, tête de serpent
des ailes, la chimère.
Validé !
Typhon il va kiffer.
Les créatures qu’on a inventées,
elles sont comme ça.
- Fin de réu ?
- Ouais.
Ah cool, on va prendre l’air ?
- Bien bossé là !
- Attendez, attendez.
ça craint pas un peu là ?
On a blindé de monstres.
ça craint !
t’imagine, les proba
ça va les gars ? Qu’est-ce qui ce passe ?
Eh mais ça c’est la créature qu’on a...
Incarnez l’héroïne Fénix
et térassez les monstres mythologiques dans
sortie, le 3 décembre.
J’ai déjà joué, en avant-Premiere.
bah je suis un dieu !
Un dieu ça a les jeux en avance.
Et ça te fait plaisir,
parce qu’on s’emmerde un peu sur le monde.
Abonne-toi, ça les aidera.
Moi de toute façon je le ferai pas.
Je m’abonne plus
à rien.